what we have here is an area that's
that's representative of the the higher
areas of the fields the areas that were
that were well drained so this probably
represents 50 to 60% of the
field the the drainage was good the
access to oxygen for the developing seed
has been good it's germinated quickly
and strongly it's got uh a green shoot
very quickly and its third Leaf is
already appearing this is
uh wet direct seeding as it should be
done these plants are
happy now what we have here is an area
that's representative of uh the
intermediate Zone shall I say when we
seated it was too wet it was a little
bit too wet and gradually during the
week it gradually dried out but it was
still wetter than we'd like it to be and
you can see the seedlings are much
smaller they've had to fight for
survival for much of the week but they
are establishing and they'll be okay
even though they're slow The
Establishment density is lower but
overall it's an acceptable
result so the seedlings were
unhappy but now they're
okay what we have here is an area
representative are of complete
failure the area areas like this maybe
five somewhere between 5 and 10% of the
field stayed wet all week they've only
just become
dry uh that was too long for the rice
plants so here we have an area that's
completely devoid of rice seedlings all
the rice seeds have
died so what we have is an even field a
non-uniform field the drier areas have
grown really well the intermediate areas
have grown okay they'll be okay but the
wetter
areas uh have been complete failures so
5 to 10% of the field we're going to
recede to give it that second chance
true uh being seed almost a week later
will mean it matures a little later but
rice does have a habit of catching up by
the time you get to flowering and
harvest so I'm not that concerned
I think in hindsight we were seduced by
technology we looked to the laser
leveling laser guided laser equipment
when in hindsight I think the small
equipment the the equipment invented
here in the Philippines would have given
us a More Level field so um don't always
assume the high-tech path is the most
effective one so we're recating small
areas just the wetter areas the the
drier areas where the rice is okay that
soil is now too dry it won't seed
successfully the rice Roots won't
penetrate the soil so there's no point
putting seed there anyway we're focusing
purely on those small very wet areas
with no rice in them at all